ah how this works busting busting you
know well I told you when my might my
daughter was very young I was in
Pittsburgh and she was six months old I
don't know if you ever heard my wife
tell this story and my daughter is six
months old and we hired a babysitter
because my wife and I were gonna go out
and have a very nice a meal and I had I
had used my wife's computer to cuz I got
home late to to rub one out like the
dirt bag I was well my child and my wife
was slept in the other room because I'm
a I need help the other room you're do
yeah and and but I just lazily shut it
because you know all the popups that
used to come off yeah they still Pablo
okay so I again I wore myself out with
the porn stuff but I did that and when
my wife opened to MapQuest where we were
gonna be for the babysitter but all that
stuff came up
basileus it was a big problem and I said
I'm very sorry I thought you do said I
know it was shut up okay right I said
that was and I blamed my friend I said I
said Johnny got a hole the computer that
scumbag and he was showing me a girl and
you know you should done I'm sorry for
this you guys absolutely right I was
jacking off last night yeah I have a
good day yeah well and go there was a
young lady and I I was intensely
embarrassed that I do it yeah
that stuff is embarrassed you been
caught chin with anything like that your
pants are cut you jacking off or killing
people no I'm lucky I know people have
been caught never tugging your buds so
I'm very very careful yeah yeah I bet
you're you cover all all these right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]